Hey traders, it's Mike here, and in this
video I'm going to talk some more about
the order flow exhaustion entry model.
Now, today is uh Tuesday, the 19th of
May, and you know, cash opened, and we
started trading lower, right? This is
the uh where is cash opening?
Right around here is cash open, and
these red lines are the lows. We started
heading down lower, got a little bit of
a bounce, and to be honest, there wasn't
much in terms of exhaustion um during
the day, but what was interesting was
there were there was a few interesting
plays here. Um you could see as we went
down, made new lows, 73.56 and a
quarter. Um went down 54 and a quarter.
We got this nice rally up where we had
our exhaustion print. So, you know, our
low was 54 and a quarter. We rallied all
the way up to 78 um just, you know, 78
and a half, more or less. And at the
high of this rally, we have our nice
exhaustion print. You know, we were
going up, we got some nice overall
positive delta, but as we were coming up
here, right? As we were forming this
top,
you could see we got green bar positive
delta, green bar positive delta, but
we've got this red bar with positive
delta right here at 319. Then this bar
on the high, positive 201. And what that
is uh that's a price action
divergence in terms of delta, because we
are going up, right? With positive
delta, right? Which is what you expect
to see with positive delta, but each bar
that we hit on these highs,
early in the bar,
overwhelmingly strong positive delta,
right? But the bar price action turns
around in the bar, bar closes on its
low, bar closes on its low. And the
second bar here, we've got that
exhaustion print of six. So,
when you have a red candle with positive
delta, that tells you that early in that
bar, that there was strong aggressive
buying, and you can see the volumes in
here, 335, 266, right? In this bar up
here, 389, 203, 268, 237. It was running
up into resting liquidity up in here.
That is why the bar has positive delta.
Once those aggressive buyers
got exhausted, and they made their
last-ditch attempt up here, they traded
six contracts.
That is sort of the kiss of death,
right? In the terms of that aggressive
buying is over, because
remember, they're lifting all this
liquidity up in here, all this liquidity
up in here. Again, we rallied from 54
and a quarter all the way up to 78.
Okay, so that's, you know, almost, uh,
you know, over over 25-point move, close
to 30 points, right?
Buyers are getting tired. They're They
can't push it any higher. This six up
here at the high, that is my sign this
move is over, right? And now, we have a
few other things also taking place. We
got this bearish prominent point of
control. We have
value area absorption as well,
coupled with the exhaustion print.
And we know
because of that exhaustion print, the
aggressive buyers are done buying,
right? And what happens? Market
immediately sells off over the next This
is a 1-minute chart. 1 2 3 4 5 6 seven
bars, right? 7 minutes. It drops from 76
down to 56. 20 points very quick. Why?
Because buyers were exhausted. We
the aggressiveness, the aggressive
buying has been removed from the market.
And once you remove that aggressive
buying, what's going to move the market
higher? Nothing. Okay? So, that is how
you could read the exhaustion in the
market. There wasn't uh many other
opportunities during the day, but there
was one interesting one that happened
around the 11, right in here. Okay? And
I I did want to mention this
this turnaround because this you know,
this caused a nice rally up also. But
here we've got our exhaustion print of
six, right? So,
let's just uh move this a little bit
closer together so it's a little easier
to see. So, you know, here was our
exhaustion print earlier.
Okay?
This was our low. Okay? So, we went from
down here up here and you can see this
level here. Every time we came up to
that area of exhaustion, another
exhaustion print right there. 10 here,
22. So, this is holding and it came down
in here. Okay? And this bar right here,
okay? This is our new swing low. We had
This was the
This was a swing low, so we came down,
hit here, went back up, came down. So,
we got this lower low exhaustion print.
And this bar right here has got a strong
negative delta minus 700. It goes a
little bit lower.
Okay? And it trades six down here. It's
got a positive delta of 99. Okay? Then
you get these two red candles negative
delta. So, it's just a little bit of
selling. This is unfortunate because you
know, this is one that
is good that you know, I would recommend
to take. It was just a little bit left
of selling, you know, I think there was
sort of this the strong selling in this
bar here wasn't done. You know, the
seller paused but then they came back
here. Okay? But what was interesting in
these two bars is this you know, they
sort of got this double bottom. This
green candle's got a negative delta
minus 111. It's got exhaustion print of
one. The second bar here has got
exhaustion print of six. It's got a very
small delta of 10.
Okay? More importantly, these two bars
both exhibit
bullish value area absorption. That's
this blue right here. Okay? For this
move up. This was the move that I was
looking for
initially, right here, right? It's just
to get this little bit of selling, I
think left over from this bar here with
the strong negative delta. You know, I
said if there's nothing wrong with
getting long here, you just get stopped
out.
Hopefully, you could have got in on the
re-entry. You know, I always say there's
markets give you a second chance to get
in. There's nothing wrong with trying to
get back in once you see further signs
of absorption plus further signs of
exhaustion. And this was a nice move
that we saw the market put in a nice
rally from. You know, we're talking
from, you know, around the 68 level all
the way up into the 90s. It even got up
above 7400.
So, you know, that was, you know, even
if you got in a very bad price of 7370,
you know, it's a nice 30-point move that
happened right there.
Now,
I always recommend traders, you know,
especially if you're trading with a
footprint and you're looking for
something very specific such as the
exhaustion print, have other charts
open. And
you know, 10 years is is a great market
to trade because
it trades a lot of size, okay? And and
that, especially if you're looking for
an exhaustion print, okay? So,
look at this. This market is selling off
into new lows, okay? You had a green bar
here. It's got 2800 here. It's 214.
This one, two contracts. This bar traded
19,000 contracts, 19.15 thousand. Look
at this delta. It's tiny, 19. So, we're
coming down, right? It's got a big
strong, you know, like strong aggressive
selling, 13,000, 11,000.
You get this bar here. It's got positive
delta of 4,000. So, it's coming down and
we're starting to see some signs of
Okay.
What? Aggressive buying coming in here,
right? With these two buying imbalances,
this one. But most importantly, is this
exhaustion print, too. 19,000 contracts
traded and it only trades two at the
low.
You think that's important? You should.
Right? It's just telling you, you know,
because again, you got the very strong
cuz I mean, look at these deltas. 6,000,
5,000, 13,000. We're pushing 25,000 in
delta.
Plus,
you know, another 1,000. Plus, another
11,000. So, over these, you know, 1 2 3
4 5 bars, we're pushing close to 35 Oh,
37,000
negative delta.
So, you know, sellers are in control.
Every time you pound into these lows,
3,000.
3,900, 2,300, 6,000, two.
What's that about?
Sellers aren't interested in selling
down here anymore. Right? It It's so
clear on the 10-years that there was
exhaustion at this low. And then, what
happens? The market, right? Look at
that. It's It puts in this
nice, methodical, slow rally. Goes up,
pulls back a little bit, sideways,
sideways. Got another exhaustion right
here of one
before rallying up. All right? And
again, the thing about uh 10-years is
the way it moves.
Right? Once it starts moving,
it's like
you know, on the on the way down, on the
move down, it's just like a ball rolling
down a hill. Now here, you know, it's
just like a turtle starting to move.
It's moving slowly back up. You know,
10-years bonds, ultra bonds, ultra tens
are great contracts for traders to look
at beyond S&P's cuz sometimes, you know,
in the S&P's,
you don't see a lot of uh signals, you
know, some days. You know, some days uh
previous days I've been showing you the
last week, you know, there was
several,
you know, today, there's just
essentially just two
tradable signals.
But, if keeping an eye on other markets,
especially very liquid markets that
trade a lot of contracts,
this has just stuck out like a sore
thumb. That, you know, you could Again,
what's your risk? You know, you're just
buying it right here. Your risk is just
right below this exhaustion print.
That's it.
To capture this move here.
Okay? So, thanks for watching this
video, guys, and I'll see you on the
next one.